[Music]
my name is max thermasen
and i'm the owner and operator of
colorglow gta
our main job is to refresh and restore
interior components of vehicles today
i'll be walking you through
how i'm restoring the driver's seat on
the 2006 ferrari 360 spyder
the problem with the driver's seat is
that over the years of use there's
obvious signs of wear and tear the
original dye has faded
it started cracking the leather has
started to wrinkle and fold up
and deform itself
the first thing that i do with this car
is i
start by removing the seat from the
vehicle itself
it makes it much easier to work on and
when i
end up spraying the die i don't have to
mask off the entire interior
once the seat is out of the car i put it
on my work table
and i start by dismantling the seat
itself
i'm removing the main bottom cushion and
the top cushion to expose the bolsters
of the seat
this makes my life a lot easier because
i gain access to all the little crevices
that are found in the seat
i've started by fully cleaning the seed
i have my own cleaning mixture
i spray the seed down and i start off
with the brush and i start agitating the
seed to lift the dirt up from the
leather
that's been in there for years this is a
very crucial step because i want a clean
working slate
the reason for that is when i'll be
applying the fillers and the dyes
that has something to stick on and
there's no grease or oils that could
alter or affect my products
i use a soft horsehair brush to get into
all the little crevices and
to clean up the threads and then i
follow up by drying it with a hair dryer
i could leave it to dry by itself but i
find it it's much quicker
i can see any parts that i miss because
they still remain
shiny and not matte
once the cleaning has been fully done
then i start by sanding the leather down
it creates trenches in the leather that
enables my
my product to bond with the leather to
have proper adhesion
i'm removing the old dye that's all
cracked up
and i'm exposing the natural height on
the seat itself
i usually start with 120 grit and i work
my way up to 400 grit
the smooth finish is needed because once
i
start applying the dye you don't want
the leather to be still
uneven when the dye lays on it it looks
natural
clean and uniform then i start filling
in any imperfections scratches with
their crack filler
our fillers are flexible because leather
is flexible and we can be using a stiff
filler
i use an artist spatula that allows me
to
fill the cracks but also remove the
excess
filler from the top surface i carefully
go around the entire seat
i let that sit to dry for a bit and once
again i go back to sanding
it creates a smooth uniform finish
i start by mixing the color in this case
the color is black so it's fairly simple
i'm pouring my base into the green cup
then i pour the black pigment
once i've established the ratio for how
consistent
i need the dye to be i move on to the
next step
and that is starting to hand rub
the dye into the leather it allows the
dye to be
sucked into those trenches and valleys
and it allows
the leather to really absorb our dye
and to hang on to it i go over the
entire seat
once i've done that i pour the dye into
my
spray gun and i add additives to my die
so in this case the additives that i've
added was
a no gloss additive usually a full
seat receives about three to four
coats of dye once i've been spraying
the white crack filler is no longer
visible
and that's what i'm aiming at i take out
my second gun
and now into that gun i mix in the same
leather base that i started with
but without any black pigment and this
serves as a clear coat
for the seat which separates the black
dye
from the user
the curing takes about a day then i go
ahead and reinstall the seat
[Music]
you